زهراء الفتاه الجميله وحسين والحاج ابو
محمد بالرغم من اختلاف اعمارهم لكنهم
تشبثوا بالحياه بعد اصابتهم بمرض الحمى
النزفيه نقلوا ومعهم اخرون بعد الاصابه من
مناطق سكناهم الاهوار الى مستشفى العزل
الصحي وسط الناصريه جنوب العراق حيث تلقوا
العلاج بعضهم اكتسب الشفاء وسيخرج قريبا
وبعضهم الاخر تحت الاشراف المباشر وفي
العموم وصل عدد المصابين في هذه المحافظه
الى 35 حاله توفي منها سته وفقا لمصادر
طبيه
[موسيقى]
اخذنا الصبح واراجح الظهر والعصر هم نفس
الوضعيه
مع تخوف المواطنين من انتشار موجه جديده
للفيروس اعلنت خليه الازمه في الناصريه
تمديد حاله الانذار الصحي اجراءات هدفها
الحد من ارتفاع الاصابات تصاحبها حملات
تفتيش لمنع الجزار العشوائيه الا في
الاماكن المرخصه القرار يعتبر ساري
المفعول حتى الثامن عشر من شهر يونيو
القادم وسيعاد النظر فيه بعد ذلك بين
القصابين في المناطق الريفيه والذين لديهم
احتكاك مباشر مع الحيوانات ومع اللحوم
لذلك نوصي
نوصي ونشدد الارشادات على ربات البيوت
وذلك باخذ الحيطه والحذر حين التعامل مع
مع اللحوم وتقطيع اللحوم وذلك بنفس الكفوف
وكذلك وضع اللحوم في الثلاجه وذلك لقتل
الفيروس
بعمليه التبريد
الوقايه واتباع النصائح الجديده التي بدات
تظهر على شكل ملصقات ومنها تبريد اللحوم
قبل الاكل لمده 24 ساعه ارشادات على
المواطنين اتباعها للحد من انتشار وباء
تعتبر الناصريه اكثر مدن العراق تضررا منه
من الناصريه شاكر عواد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات